How is one program, let's say an
email, protected from the misbehavior of another program,
say the web browser. This is where memory
related operating system abstractions come into play. In
particular, the operating system provides address space as
an abstraction for each process that is distinct
from one another. So the data and the
code that corresponds to a particular program is
contained in a container which is
called the address space. That's the abstraction
provided by the operating system. And
this address space abstraction of the operating
system is implemented by whatever hardware
capabilities that the underlying processor architecture provides
you. Processor and memory are the most
precious resources. And, what we've done is
a quick review to understand the abstractions
in the operating system for managing these resources.